tom and tom here we are we have set the
vibe with some tom's good loving but i
want to start somewhere else yeah
sandoval can you admit that schwartz and
sandy's is not the name it's not it
[Laughter]
that's actually a question for both of
us what's the name we're still working
on the name
actually we
have settled on a name and it's schwartz
and sandy's what your tom really likes
the name that he came up with
my tom hates it yeah i think it's yeah
they are
opposite sides the people have spoken
and it's a unanimous
the public does not like it but we're
gonna make them like it
once you come and experience
the schwartz and sandy experience oh
you're gonna love it are we committing
to this name then are we
reclaiming it and let me uh people
okay
by the way i bought like seven domains
for uh for us today okay as long as you
didn't buy schwartz and sandy's we're
good of course i bought that when you go
into our place the
the name will become the place the place
will become the name you know that will
be the association but schwartz and
sandy's there's only one schwartz and
one sandy in that combination so you
know what i mean like i
i feel like it's you're getting to know
us even a little bit more because this
is more of like our like
our love child essentially this is the
love child okay that's this is the sales
pitch this is the love child how far
away are we from
the doors of schwartz and sandy's being
open to the public we're shooting for
the end of the year um but
worst case scenario it will be uh early
2022. yeah okay
we're we're full steam ahead right now
so we got like yeah we have all kinds of
price sometimes we need to be reeled in
because me and tom
especially especially tom
yeah we have you guys you got those
ideas too
the gears are constantly going lisa kind
of hinted at this to me she said i think
those two
you're not in over your heads but maybe
didn't know all the things that come
along with launching a business like
this oh my god i need a hug yeah
[Laughter]
you're
we are each other's emotional support
trust me you know business and
friendship don't always mix it seems to
work for the two of you but has
bringing business into this relationship
changed your friendship at all better or
worse
it's it i'm not gonna lie i i mean in
the beginning it strained it and you'll
see that play out schwartz and i are
opening up our own bar it's a complete
show
keep her out of it i want katie to come
in and train stashes to do it our bond
is unbreakable yeah but it did it did
put a lot of strain
on our on our friendship professionally
and personally this is intense bryce
this is not a business for the faint of
heart there is a moment in the trailer
where lisa says this is just a [ __ ]
firework waiting to explode it already
has what is that about uh i i honestly
don't remember exactly um
it could have been
uh
maybe something between
katie and i um i'm not exactly sure i
think it was i think it was let's unpack
all that then all the katy stuff because
it's
here we go happening
um
schwartz how do you feel
it's about okay it sucks because it's
both your best friend speaks ill of your
wife and your wife speaks ill of your
best friend and not to mention in in a
very high stakes moment time is money
right now we're under a lot of pressure
and like listen that's my wife i love
her more than anything in the world so i
have her back but also sometimes you
know
my friend tom i have a ton of respect
for him he makes good points he has a
point too and i i it's tough being in
the middle um i find myself there a lot
though and i think i do okay with it i'm
a decent mediator i think this you'll
see you'll see this season i i think i
sort of lost it a little bit i did lose
we all lose it a little bit i lost it a
little bit we all lose it a little bit
come on get over it
are you making me feel like a [ __ ]
cycle ah this whole conversation of
steamrolling comes up i'm not the only
person that notices that you let tom
steamroll you that's not true though
yes it is i'm torn right now because i
know what's gonna happen if i do talk to
him about this he's gonna steamroll me
about steamrolling me and i don't wanna
get steamrolled sandoval what's your
take on that do you feel use steamroll
are there things you could have done
differently now knowing how things shook
out
look i saw this situation coming from a
mile away and that's one of the reasons
why you know i love katie we're great
friends or family you know but
i
i know that because we have strong
personalities like this is why i wanted
to kind of keep this sort of just
between schwartz and i and not bring in
everybody else so sandoval where do you
and katie stand today you say your
family which i think also helps to
explain why things get so tense does it
all work out in the end does it all come
out in the wash look we're in a good
space right now um that could always
change
i don't want it to change i don't either
um but obviously you know when we're
gonna be re-watching and sort of
re-experiencing everything that happened
this summer i'm sure that those old
feelings like they always do they'll
come back up and we might you know it
might cause a little friction here and
there we try to keep that we try to like
uh leave that at the uh what do you want
to say like leave that off
this season feels like a fresh chapter
for this group for the show it could be
like a make or break it kind of moment
in a lot of ways
what do you see the evolution of the
show being from here on out now knowing
kind of what the dynamics are with this
pared down group of people
well i mean we're always optimistic we
got a lot of cool things we're working
on the new bar i feel like the show has
a lot of room to grow and a deep deep
well of history and friendship to pull
from and uh i still feel like it has a
lot of life oh yeah i mean we're just
getting started like there is so much
so much to do i really believe that and
you're gonna be like well of course
you're gonna say that you're on the show
if i didn't think that i probably just
wouldn't say anything but i really do
think it has a lot of life left yeah
well i was i was talking to lisa about
this i said it's refreshing to see
the fourth wall is coming down it's like
it's not fully down but some bricks have
been pulled out we can see through it
and we're acknowledging
the the life that has been created
because of the show in a lot of ways
which talking
is yeah which is really great because
you know i understand trying to preserve
the
you know
you know us you know working at sir and
all that stuff and and trying to you
know make ends meet and hustling get
that next gig to get to the next place
in life like we're still doing that i
feel like it's it's just a nice thing
for for the audience
it's it's respectful to the audience to
not ignore the obvious
and the one of the things that i love
about our friend group our show in
general is the evolution of it you know
um that you're seeing us start from like
here and go to here maybe go back down
yeah yeah up to here maybe go way back
down here it's not like this but yeah it
hasn't been like this no is there
anything coming up this season that
you're bracing for impact for that you
know happened and the audience is gonna
feel some type of way about well yeah of
course of course there is but
i don't want to get into it uh i mean
i'm kind of dreading to see like some of
the stuff that happened between me you
and katie play out yeah because it got
really intense bryce at some points like
that
is katie still a part of
the business vision of i'm just gonna
have to even see and find out you'll see
and not to be like not to me
but it's you'll see it's
nuanced and um yeah yeah i think i think
there's there's a there's some surprises
coming and and i'm excited for everybody
to see that i'm excited for everybody to
see like how this everything just sort
of pans out and works out and all the
little things that are coming yeah and
outside of us there's some very very
heated moments to come and some
beautiful ones funny ones that's a nice
balance yeah this season i can't
understand you oh it's because sandoval
stick is in your mouth you know we have
all these other things going on
obviously we're super stoked about this
whiskey well congratulations on this
congratulations on schwartz and sandy's
i'm gonna have to sit with that name for
a minute you said it bryce you said it
[Music]
you